Traduttore: Marco Cigolotti
Revisore: Angela Dettori
Buonasera.
Conoscete?
Lago di Como.
Io sono nato in provincia di Como,
qualche anno fa.
I Monti Lariani per me
sono stati proprio la prima base
dove iniziare quelle che io chiamerò
"le riunioni con me".
Quando io dovevo staccare
andavo su in montagna, spesso,
e dicevo "vado in riunione con me"
e frequentavo i Monti Lariani.
In tutti i modi, in tutte le stagioni,
in tutte le condizioni.
Queste riunioni con me
erano riunioni di...
Parlo di 13-14 anni,
a volte non andavo a scuola
per vedere i galli forcelli volare via...
Queste riunioni erano
tra creatività, tra la fantasia,
tra la voglia di fare, progetti.
Riunioni con la propria persona.
A me piaceva, mi trovavo bene.
Durante queste scampagnate
incontravo spesso anche amici,
conoscevi gente
e, soprattutto, incontravo persone
che abitavano in montagna.
A me, più che l'alpinista,
ha sempre affascinato il vecchietto
che abitava, magari,
10 minuti fuori dal paese.
Cioè, il vivere tutti i giorni,
quello che devi fare tutti i giorni
per portare a casa il risultato.
A me piaceva questo, mi prendeva.
E cominciavano anche le prime difficoltà.
A cercare di capire,
prima di dirlo a qualcun altro,
a cercare di capire che mestiere è...
In che professione rientra
fare ciò che comporta
il vivere in montagna?
Non rientra in nessuna professione.
Allora, ad un certo punto,
più che l'usare l'attrezzatura
— l'attrezzatura non nasce
per pestar neve la domenica,
poi è diventata mezzo,
ma l'attrezzatura nasce, prima di tutto,
per portare a casa un risultato
in determinate condizioni.
Per andare a caccia,
per procurarsi il cibo,
per raggiungere un paese, gli sci...
Nasce per riuscire a vivere
in determinate condizioni.
E a me ha sempre
affascinato questo, il "vivere".
Ed è la fase anche delle prime domande,
perché i Monti Lariani...
Questo per me sarà una tappa fondamentale.
Questo è il primo 4000,
a 15 anni su al Bernina.
Ci ritornerò ancora più volte
ed è un pò il punto fermo,
quello dove partono
un pò tutte le decisioni.
Iniziano i primi scontri forti,
perché la voglia di abitare, di vivere,
di fare quelle cose era forte,
ma si scontrava con una educazione
e con le persone vicine.
Uno dei punti fermi
dell'educazione era che
le cose di passione
non ti danno da vivere.
Prima porti a casa il risultato,
poi fai quello che ti sta a cuore.
Ho capito, ma a me piace fare quello.
Sì, però non è un mestiere.
Facciamolo diventare un mestiere.
Però, ovviamente, a 16, 17 anni
non hai quella presenza
di porti di fronte
a un modo di organizzare le cose
da parte di genitori, di amici,
di società, di tutto,
per cui cerchi,
cosa che non sono riuscito ancora oggi,
cercare di far capire, di dimostrare...
C'è ancora oggi gente che viene su,
dopo vent'anni che c'è la baita
che conosce, che vede, che si ferma lì
e pensa che tutto sia possibile
grazie ai soldi.
Pensa questo.
Incredibile.
Allora, ad un certo punto
nascono le domande forti.
Periodo dei 20, 25 anni,
faccio altre esperienze,
faccio altre scelte...
Anche perché in una
delle riunioni fondamentali di me con me,
io avevo messo la razionalità
come punto fermo, come riferimento,
come ultima parola.
Per cui tutti i progetti, le idee,
vuoi fare una cosa o l'altra,
la razionalità vagliava il tutto.
Se la razionalità dava l'ok si faceva,
altrimenti era irrazionale,
non si faceva.
Ad un certo punto la domanda è:
alla fine cos'è vivere?
A me è sempre stato insegnato:
mi raccomando, crea sicurezze,
perché un domani non si sa mai.
Va bene... fammi arrivare a questo domani!
'Sto "domani non si sa mai",
"mi raccomando, fai in modo
che non ti manchi nulla".
Ma allora, in una delle famose riunioni,
dicevo, se ogni attimo della vita
è un'incognita,
io non so cosa mi succederà
tra 10 minuti, ma neanche tra un minuto,
se tutto il mio fare
è orientato ad annullare l'imprevisto,
perché lo vedo come qualcosa
che può minare...
Io non vivo.
Perché rifiuto la vita,
perché la vita è fatta di imprevisti,
è fatta di attimi.
Allora, più che annullare l'imprevisto,
insegnami a cavalcarlo,
educami a prendere dall'imprevisto
quello che può andare bene per me,
a non averne paura.
Perché altrimenti io continuerò
a creare sicurezze,
ma in realtà non creo niente.
A meno che uno lavori nelle assicurazioni,
allora lì per forza...
"Ah, sì guardi, perché può succedere".
Zero, esci fuori.
Ma io voglio vivere, voglio vivere.
Allora: vivere cos'è?
Fare famiglia, viaggiare,
documentare, cercare?
In una di queste riunioni viene fuori: no!
Non sono queste cose,
per me vivere è vivermi.
Cioè, prendo il mio potenziale
e me lo gioco.
Prendo quello che sono,
voglio vivermi fino in fondo.
La capacità di sentire, di sudare,
di camminare, di vedere, di ascoltare.
Io voglio vivermi fino in fondo.
Ad un certo punto, a 26 anni,
riunione memorabile in cima al Bernina.
Ormai mi conoscevano
anche le cole lì in alto.
Riunione memorabile in cima al Bernina,
si passa dalla razionalità,
via, viene destituita.
Viene affidato il ruolo fondamentale
alla passione, passione per la montagna.
A me veniva naturale far quelle cose lì.
Inutile che vado a fare un'altra cosa
che non mi sento.
Quando facevo delle esperienze forti,
io stavo in giro,
davo una mano
a chi incontravo nelle baite, stavo bene.
Tornavo a casa e non è che stavo male,
perché facevi delle cose,
facevo bene delle cose,
aiutavo anche mio padre...
Ma star bene era un'altra cosa.
Quando senti che il motore gira
è tutta un'altra cosa.
Allora in cima al Bernina
i "se" e i "ma" sono stati sostituiti
da "scelgo" o "non scelgo".
I "se" e i "ma" non servono a niente.
Ho imparato a fare a meno
dei "se" e dei "ma" in un secondo tempo,
quando mi son fatto male ed ero da solo.
Tu scendi, ti fai male:
"Ah, però se stavo attento".
Non è che elaborando 30 "se"
la spalla ti va a posto.
No, finita l'elaborazione dei 30 "se"
tu rimani ancora con le stesse condizioni
e devi venirne fuori.
Allora cosa serve?
Allora ad un certo punto
lascio perdere i "se" e i "ma",
"scelgo" o "non scelgo".
Scelgo di fare una cosa,
non scelgo di far l'altra.
A me non interessa trovare il motivo
per cui ho fatto o non ho fatto una cosa,
a me interessa farla,
dare forma a quello che ho dentro.
Lascio il compito alla passione.
È come se cambi il sistema operativo,
passi da una cosa all'altra,
cambi il modo di impostare le cose,
cambia tutto.
Vado a cercare un posto
e vado a vivere lì.
Ciao. "Sei esagerato".
"Va bene che ti piace la montagna,
però così è troppo".
Ad un certo punto...
Queste sono le Grigne.
Sempre su in Grigna, di qua e di là,
aiutare, fare e disfare...
Una cosa: difficoltà enormi,
perché tutto remava contro,
perché era un modo, trent'anni fa,
completamente...
Come fai a mangiare,
come fai a mantenerti?
Vai a vivere in montagna
perché ti piacciono quelle cose,
ho capito, ma come fai?
Però una cosa, sottile.
Una sensazione di serenità e di libertà.
Io questa non la faccio scappare,
io mi aggrappo a questa e me la tengo.
Dentro.
Fuori c'era il mondo e il finimondo.
Ma dentro una sensazione sottile
di serenità e di libertà.
Va bene.
Ad un certo punto cerco il posto
organizzandomi giorno per giorno,
sto in giro quasi un paio d'anni
in tenda, estate e inverno,
da Courmayeur fino in Friuli
per cercare il posto
con almeno un'ora a piedi,
panorama incredibile,
acqua di sorgente, isolato,
senza altre baite attorno
e sole anche in inverno.
Lo trovo in Valsesia, sopra Alagna,
a 2100 metri di altezza.
Arrivo a casa, sento mio fratello,
perché poi anche lì
ci si parlava e non parlava
con un pò tutto il comprensorio,
e dico: "Ho trovato un posto fantastico".
Lui pensava una casetta fuori dal paese.
Finalmente,
sei in giro come un'anima in pena.
Ho trovato un posto fantastico.
(Risate)
A 2100 metri d'altezza.
La razionalità non si dà pace.
Ma non esiste!
Non si possono fare queste cose qua!
Riunioni...
La razionalità va dalla passione
e le dice:
"Sì, ho capito... vi porto un elemento
che vi dimostra
che questo non è fattibile".
La fattibilità.
Per fortuna che non c'erano
gli studi di fattibilità vent'anni fa,
sennò adesso ero in una stanzetta,
altro che essere qua.
Io dicevo: ma la fattibilità...
Se io ho un cancello
e devo passare con una macchina,
io ti posso dire se è fattibile.
Misuro e vedo.
Ma riguardo una vita,
riguardo alla persona
come fai a dire se è fattibile o no?
Entrano in gioco troppe variabili,
troppe varianti.
Non posso a priori dirti se è fattibile.
Ma anche voi, penso,
quando andate a fare un viaggio
o a fare un giro,
vi trovate con l'amico:
"Dai, ci troviamo dopo
così ti dico com'è andata".
Perché "ci troviamo dopo"?
Diglielo subito come andrà a finire.
Ma non puoi saperlo,
devi prima viverla la cosa.
Allora la fattibilità non esiste.
In questo caso.
E soprattutto l'ho sperimentato
con gli istituti di credito,
quando devi chiedere un prestito.
Allora,
il commento più tranquillo è stato:
"Signor Pozzi,
queste cose non le facciamo".
Non è che ti ho chiesto di andare
in mutande in piazza.
(Risate)
Il commento più a favore
è stato di un vice direttore
appassionato di montagna:
"Mi faccia sapere come va a finire".
(Risate)
Va bene, te lo farò sapere.
Ma cosa sto chiedendo io?
La razionalità,
forte di queste situazioni,
in una di queste riunioni dice:
"Vi porto un elemento
che vi convince
che questa cosa non è fattibile".
Questa in settembre.
È sempre quella, comunque.
Allora, in una di queste riunioni
chiama il soldo.
Il soldo entra dentro.
C'è la passione, la fantasia,
la creatività.
Eravamo lì tutti insieme, c'ero anch'io.
Il soldo dice:
"Senza di me non si va da nessuna parte".
Al che tutti dicono "Come?"
"Io porto la fattibilità delle cose".
"Se ci sono io non vi mancherà nulla".
Un casino totale perché uno dice no,
io non ci sto.
Ma allora, tutto il resto,
tutto quello che è la persona,
il valore di una persona,
la sua fantasia... non vale niente?
Io non ci sto.
Discussione incredibile,
ad un certo punto,
per mettere fine a tutto, ho detto:
"Ok, d'ora in poi tu, razionalità, sarai
a completa disposizione della passione."
A completa disposizione. A completa.
Organizza, fai, a completa disposizione.
Tu, soldo, non sarai mai il motivo,
la ragione per fare o non fare una cosa.
Tu sei un mezzo.
Come uso i ramponi quando c'è ghiaccio.
Come uso la sega per tagliare la legna.
Ti rispetto.
Faremo cose insieme.
Ma non sarai mai il motivo,
la ragione per cui, da parte mia,
vale la pena fare o non fare una cosa.
Primo. Secondo,
non ti azzardare a metterti in mezzo,
perché tu non sei un elemento naturale.
Tu sei una convenzione.
Io in natura non ti trovo.
Non c'è una pianta di soldi
che nasce, cresce, muore.
Non c'è il soldo in natura.
Per cui, quando si pretende di gestire
degli elementi naturali
col parametro del soldo,
non tornano i conti.
Come fai a quantificare
una carezza, un valore?
Dare il valore ad uno sguardo?
Non puoi.
Quando si cerca di quantificare,
di parametrizzare tutto col soldo,
snaturi le cose
e non vai più da nessuna parte.
Quando uno inizia a snaturare le cose,
inaridisce,
che è la cosa peggiore
che possa succedere a una persona.
Mai vissuta come sfida,
mai vissuta come reazione.
Ne ho piene le scatole, vado via.
Vissuta con amore.
Fai quello che sei,
fai quello che ti viene naturale fare.
A te non pesa.
Le difficoltà, comunque,
rimangono fuori di te.
Poi ci sarebbe
tutta la costruzione della baita,
perché la baita è stata costruita.
Questo è in inverno,
ero andato a fare Natale,
perché per me era già casa,
ero proprietario del rudere.
Qua con la tenda, i primi lavori.
Questo è il primo cane,
sto smontando la tenda.
Questo con le tende.
Che poi c'erano difficoltà incredibili.
Un direttore che mi disse:
"Sì, ti facciamo il mutuo entro Natale".
Io entro Natale dico all'elicottero
e al materiale: "Vi pago".
Non ce la facciamo
perché al 18 dicembre mi chiama:
"Non si fa niente".
Una ditta di Belluno,
che non è vicino alla Valsesia,
cercava gente a mettere reti.
Vado a Belluno,
mi faccio assumere, per 6 mesi,
finché ho fatto il mutuo con la banca,
poi mi sono licenziato
perché volevo fare gli interni.
Sono andato a lavorare ancora
quando non avevo più in tasca niente.
Gennaio.
Il bed and breakfast.
Adesso uno può venire su,
fermarsi e stare tranquillo.
Il bed and breakfast
nasce da un'incidente.
Lusso la spalla. Sono fermo.
Vado dal sindaco.
Però, nel frattempo, la gente chiedeva
di fermarsi per vedere l'alba.
Vado dal sindaco e dico:
"Io sono in queste condizioni,
se do la possibilità a uno di fermarsi..."
"Ben venga".
Apro il bed and breakfast,
ma chi mi garantisce che viene su gente?
Provi.
È questo muoversi
tra le situazioni della vita,
tra i fatti della vita
che non puoi prevedere a priori.
Non posso prevedere che viene su gente.
Praticamente io
ho la tendenza a questo obiettivo...
Le cole le conoscete?
Qua ero isolato dalla neve.
Sono i gracchi di montagna.
Perché, nel frattempo,
la baita è stata messa a punto.
Non nasce come attività ricettiva.
Nasce come dar forma
alla passione di una persona
per cui viene messa a punto, è un motore.
Dopo due anni in tenda, avere un tetto,
anche con i cellophane alle finestre,
era tanta roba.
E allora continui in quella direzione.
Queste sono le cole.
Hanno una capacità di volare
che è fantastica.
Tu le vedi quando c'è bufera,
si alzano nel vento.
Fanno di quei giochi,
vedono un boccone, scendono,
il vento le spara su a 40 metri,
ritornano giù.
Io le chiamo "i giocolieri dell'aria".
Perché veramente
sono i giocolieri dell'aria.
Uno dei miei obiettivi,
forse il principale,
in questi anni e prima, è di avere,
nelle situazioni della vita,
la stessa dimestichezza
che hanno loro hanno con l'aria.
Grazie.
(Applausi)